PURSUANT TOTHE PROVISIONS OF THE
PROCLAMATION OF GOVERNOR NEWSOM,
THE 2023 2024 SECOND
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION WILL COME
TO ORDER PURSUANT TO SECTION
9150 OF THE GOVERNMENT CODE.
ERIKA CONTRERAS, SECRETARY OF
THE SENATE. KATRINA RODRIGUEZ,
SERGEANT OF ARMS, AND MATTHEW
BURNS, MINUTE CLERK, ARE IN
THEIR RESPECTIVE PLACES WITH THE
MEMBERS AND OUR GUESTS. PLEASE
RISE WILL BE LED IN THE PRAYER
BY SENATOR STERN, AFTER WHICH
WE'RE GOING TO ASK EACH AND
EVERY ONE OF YOU TO PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING FOR THE PLEDGE
OF ALLEGIANCE. SENATOR STERN.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDENT. PSALM
3418. THE LORD IS CLOSE TO THE
BROKENHEARTED AND SAVES THOSE
WHO ARE CRUSHED IN SPIRIT.
GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL GOD, WE
PRAY FOR ALL THOSE WHOSE LIVES
HAVE BEEN TOUCHED BY THE TRAGEDY
OF WARS. FOR THOSE WHO MOURN,
IMMERSE THEM IN YOUR LOVE AND
LEAD THEM THROUGH THEIR
SUFFERING. IN YOUR CONSOLING
ARMS. FOR THOSE WHO BRING
COMFORT, BE PRESENT IN BOTH THE
WORDS THEY USE AND IN ALL THAT'S
LEFT UNSPOKEN. FILL EACH HEART
WITH TRUST AND LOVE. HELP EACH
OF US TO CONTRIBUTE TO THE PEACE
THAT WE SO GREATLY DESIRE.
INSPIRE POLITICIANS,
PEACEMAKERS, SOLDIERS. HOSTAGES.
RELIEF WORKERS WITH THE ENERGY
AND THE DETERMINATION TO REPAIR
THE WORLD SO THAT ALL CAN
EXPERIENCE COMPASSION,
SUSTENANCE, REPENTANCE,
FORGIVENESS, HEALING, SECURITY,
AND YOUR UNIVERSAL LOVE. MAY A
DURABLE PEACE EMERGE OUT OF
GREAT SUFFERING AND GREAT LOVE.
AMEN. PLEASE JOIN ME IN THE
PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE. I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG OF THE
UNITED STATES OF AMERICA, AND TO
THE REPUBLIC FOR WHICH IT STANDS.
ONE NATION UNDER GOD,
INDIVISIBLE, WITH LIBERTY AND
JUSTICE FOR ALL. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE, WE'RE
NOW GOING TO OBSERVE A MOMENT OF
SILENCE, A MOMENT OF SILENCE IN
REMEMBRANCE OF ALL THOSE WHO
LOST THEIR LIVES, INCLUDING THE
VICTIMS OF HAMAS'S ATTACK ON
ISRAEL ON OCTOBER SEVENTH, THE
PALESTINIAN AND ISRAELI VICTIMS
OF THE ONGOING CONFLICT. TO ALL
THOSE AFFECTED BY THE VIOLENCE
AND SUFFERING THROUGHOUT THE
BROADER REGION. LET US PRAY FOR
PEACE. RECOMMIT OURSELVES TO
BRINGING EVERY HOSTAGE HOME AND
WORK TOWARDS THE END OF WAR AND
A JUST RESOLUTION FOR ALL. IF I
COULD ASK ALL TO PLEASE RISE FOR
A MOMENT OF SILENCE.
THANK YOU. MR. SECRETARY, CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? ELLEN.
I'LL GO. ARCHULETA. ASHBY.
ATKINS. BECKER. BLAKE. SPEER.
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. CORTEZ.
DALLEY. DODD. TORAZO. EGGMAN.
GLAZER. GONZALEZ. GROVE.
HURTADO. JONES. LAIRD. LIMÓN.
MCGUIRE. MENGIBAR. MIN. NEWMAN.
NGUYEN. NILO. OCHOA. PADILLA.
PORTANTINO. ROTH. RUBIO. SATO.
SKINNER. SMALL. CUEVAS. STERN.
UMBERG. WAHAB. WIENER. WILK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. MR.
SECRETARY, MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE, A QUORUM IS NOW PRESENT.
SENATORS, THE SECRETARY WILL
READ THE PROCLAMATION OF THE
GOVERNOR. GOVERNOR'S
PROCLAMATION I, GAVIN NEWSOM,
GOVERNOR OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA, IN ACCORDANCE WITH
SECTION THREE B OF ARTICLE FOUR
OF THE CALIFORNIA CONSTITUTION,
HEREBY CONVENE THE LEGISLATURE
OF THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO
ASSEMBLE AN EXTRAORDINARY
SESSION IN SACRAMENTO,
CALIFORNIA, ON THE 31ST DAY OF
AUGUST, 2024, AT A TIME TO BE
DETERMINED FOR THE FOLLOWING
PURPOSES. TO CONSIDER AND ACT
UPON LEGISLATION NECESSARY TO Ã.
AUTHORIZE THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION TO ADOPT REGULATIONS
THAT WOULD REQUIRE CALIFORNIA
REFINERS OF TRANSPORTATION FUELS
TO DEMONSTRATE RESUPPLY PLANS
AND ARRANGEMENTS THAT ARE
ADEQUATE TO ADDRESS LOSSES IN
PRODUCTION FROM REFINERY
MAINTENANCE BEFORE PLANNED
MAINTENANCE MAY BE SCHEDULED AND
PERMITTED, WHILE ALSO ACCOUNTING
FOR PROTECTING THE HEALTH AND
SAFETY OF REFINERY EMPLOYEES AND
THE PUBLIC. B AUTHORIZE THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION TO
IMPOSE MINIMUM INVENTORY
REQUIREMENTS ON REFINERS TO KEEP
TRANSPORTATION FUEL SUPPLY
STABLE. C MAKE OTHER NECESSARY
CHANGES TO REAFFIRM AND
STRENGTHEN THE AUTHORITY OF THE
CALIFORNIA ENERGY COMMISSION AND
THE DIVISION OF PETROLEUM MARKET
OVERSIGHT TO IMPLEMENT THE
PROVISIONS OF SB X1 TWO,
INCLUDING BY NOTIFYING THE
ADVISORY COMMITTEE THAT INFORMS
THOSE AGENCIES ACTION. D MAKE
CONFORMING CHANGES TO EXISTING
LAW CONSISTENT WITH PARAGRAPHS
A, B, AND C GAVIN NEWSOM,
GOVERNOR OF CALIFORNIA. THANK
YOU SO MUCH, MR. SECRETARY, FOR
READING THE PROCLAMATION OF THE
GOVERNOR. MEMBERS, OUR NEXT
ORDER OF BUSINESS IS MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS. MADAM MAJORITY
LEADER, YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU, MR. PRESIDING
OFFICER. MR. PRESIDENT, I MOVE
THE OFFICERS, THE COMMITTEE ON
RULES, THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE ON
FUEL SUPPLY AND PRICE SPIKES,
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE AND
THE STANDING RULES OF THE
SENATE. ACCEPT SENATE RULE 12
FOR THE 2023 2024 REGULAR
SESSION TO BE ADOPTED FOR THE 20
2324 SECOND EXTRAORDINARY
SESSION. THANK YOU, MADAM
MAJORITY LEADER. SENATORS, WE'RE
GOING TO DO THIS VOTE
DIFFERENTLY THAN WE TYPICALLY
DO. THIS WILL BE BY VOICE VOTE.
WE'RE FIRST GOING TO ASK FOR
THOSE WHO ARE IN FAVOR BY
STATING AYE. THEN WE'RE GOING TO
ASK FOR THOSE WHO ARE OPPOSED
WITH A NO. THIS MOTION WILL BE
ADOPTED ONCE AGAIN BY A VOICE
VOTE. ALL THOSE IN FAVOR, PLEASE
STATE AYE AYE. THANK YOU. ALL
THOSE OPPOSED, PLEASE STATE NO.
NO. NO. NO. WELL THE AYES HAVE
IT AND THE MOTION CARRIES THE
OATH OF OFFICE WILL BE DEEMED
COMPLETE FOR THE ELECTED
OFFICIALS. THE NEXT ORDER OF
BUSINESS UNDER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS IS SCR ONE. SENATOR
GONZALEZ, YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU. I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO TAKE UP SCR ONE
WITHOUT REFERENCE TO COMMITTEE
AND OR FILE. THANK YOU SO MUCH,
MADAM SENATOR. WITHOUT OBJECTION.
SUCH WILL BE THE ORDER.
SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE READ
THE RESOLUTION? SENATE
CONSTITUTIONAL RESOLUTION ONE BY
CONCURRENT RESOLUTION ONE BY
SENATOR GONZALEZ, RELATIVE TO
THE JOINT RULES FOR THE 20 2324
SECOND EXTRAORDINARY SESSION.
MADAM MAJORITY LEADER, YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU. THIS
RESOLUTION PRESENTS THE JOINT
RULES FOR THE SECOND
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION. I ASK FOR
AN AYE VOTE. MEMBERS OF THE
SENATE, ANY DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THIS MATTER LOOKING FOR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THIS
MATTER? HEARING. SEEING NONE.
MR. SECRETARY, CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL? ALLEN? AYE.
ALVARADO. GILL. NO. ARCHULETA.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ATKINS. BECKER.
AYE, AYE. BLAKE. SPEER. AYE.
BRADFORD. AYE. CABALLERO. CORTEZ.
AYE. DALLY. NÓ. DODD. DURAZO.
AYE. EGGMAN. AYE. GLAZER. AYE.
AYE. GONZALEZ. AYE AYE. GROVE.
NO. HURTADO. AYE. JONES. NO. NO.
LAIRD. AYE. LIMÓN. AYE AYE.
MCGUIRE. AYE. MENGIBAR. MEN.
NEWMAN. NGUYEN. NO. MELO. COBO.
NO. PADILLA. AYE. PORTANTINO.
AYE. AYE. ROTH. AYE. RUBIO. AYE.
AYE. SEYARTO. NÓ. NO. SKINNER.
AYE. SMALL. CUEVAS. AYE. STERN.
AYE. AYE. UMBERG. WAHAB. AYE.
WIENER. AYE. WILK. NÓ. NO. CAN
WE PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONCE? CALL THE ABSENT
MEMBERS ONCE. ATKINS. CABALLERO.
DODD. MENGIBAR MEN. NEWMAN. MILO.
UMBERG. AYES 24. NOES EIGHT. THE
RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED. SENATORS.
THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS UNDER
MOTIONS AND RESOLUTIONS IS
SUSPENSION OF THE SENATE RULES.
SENATOR GONZALEZ, YOU MAY
PROCEED. THANK YOU, MR.
PRESIDENT. I MOVE TO SUSPEND THE
SENATE RULES AS THEY RELATE TO
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE, ALLOWING THE
BILL TO BE READ A SECOND TIME.
UPON BEING REPORTED FROM FISCAL
COMMITTEE TOMORROW, WE SEE
SENATOR COR. FOR WHAT REASON DO
YOU RISE? IN SPITE OF OUR TIME
OFF TO REFLECT ON OUR AVERSION
TO SUSPENDING THE RULES, WE
STILL WISH TO SUSPEND OR TO
OPPOSE SUSPENDING THE RULES.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH. THANK YOU
SIR. WE'D LIKE TO LOOK TO SEE IF
THERE'S ANY OBJECTION TO USING
THE PREVIOUS ROLL CALL. SEEING
NONE. SEEING. NO OBJECTION. AYES
24. NOES EIGHT. THE SENATE RULES
ARE SUSPENDED. THANK YOU SO
MUCH. THE NEXT ORDER OF BUSINESS
IS COMMITTEE ANNOUNCEMENTS.
SENATOR BRADFORD, THE CHAIR OF
THE SPECIAL COMMITTEE, YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. COME ON DOWN. WHAT
ARE WE DOING? HI. YES. UPON
ADJOURNMENT, WILL BE MEETING IN
ROOM 2100 TO SPECIAL COMMITTEE
ON FUELS. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU, MR. CHAIR. LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN, AS WE SAID IN THE
BEGINNING OF THIS SESSION, WE'D
LIKE TO BE ABLE TO MOVE QUICKLY
AND EFFICIENTLY. AND WE HAVE
DONE THAT HERE WITH THIS
SESSION. IF THERE IS NO FURTHER
BUSINESS, THE SECOND
EXTRAORDINARY SESSION WILL STAND
IN RECESS, AND WE'RE GOING TO
CONVENE RECONVENE FRIDAY,
OCTOBER 11TH AT 10:30 A.M.
MEMBERS, THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
YOUR TIME TODAY.